hi in this module i'm going to briefly
introduce the idea of differential
programming
and differential programming kind of
just runs off with ideas of computation
graphs and back propagation that we
developed for simple neural networks
um there's really enough to say here to
fill up an entire course at least so i'm
going to keep trying to keep things
pretty high level but i will try to
highlight the power of composition
so differential programming is closely
related deep learning i've adopted the
former term as an attempt to be more
precise in terms of highlighting the
mechanics of writing models as you would
code
so if you look around at deep learning
today there's some pretty complex models
which have many layers potential
mechanisms residual connections
to name a few and this could be quite
overwhelming at first glance
but when you look closer
you'll notice that these complex models
are actually composed of functions and
these functions themselves are composed
of smaller functions so this is the
programming part of differential
programming which allows you to build up
increasingly more sophisticated model
without losing track of what's going on
so let's begin with our familiar example
the three layer neural network
so remember that in
three layer neural network we start with
our feature vector
this case is a six dimensional vector
and we left multiply by a matrix
um i've drawn some lines here to help us
interpret this matrix as a set of rows
so each row corresponds to a hidden unit
and i'm going to take the dot product of
each row with
the input vector to produce a hidden
vector of dimension four
i'm going to add a bias term
and then i'm going to apply an
activation function element wise for
example the relu or the logistic
now i have a vector
and now i can do the same thing again i
apply
a matrix add a bias term
apply an activation function
apply a matrix which happens to be a
vector i so i get a scalar and i add a
simple scalar bias term and i get a
score which then i can happily drive
regression or take the sign to drive
classification
so
what i want to
do now
is to factor out this kind of complex
looking expression into a reusable
component which i'm going to call it
feed forward
so we're going to see a lot of these box
diagrams which are going to represent
functions that we can reuse and have a
nice intro
so the feedforward function takes in an
input vector x
and produces another an output vector
which could be of a different
dimensionality
and the way to interpret what v4 are
doing is performing one step of
processing
in particular what that processing is is
uh taking this input vector
multiplying by a matrix adding a bias
term and applying an activation function
okay
so this is a
function or a program but unlike normal
programming it's underspecified because
the red
numbers here are parameters which are
private to this function which are going
to be set
in tune later via back propagation
so now we can write our three-legged
neural network using feedforward and the
way i'm going to do this is
score is equal to
you take
x or this should be phi of x
um
and you
apply fee forward b forward feedforward
and you can write this as feedforward
cubed to as to be more compact
so this is a very compact way of writing
something that would otherwise be
quite complicated
so now let's suppose we want to do image
classification
we need some way of representing images
so the feedforward function that we just
introduced takes a vector as input
and we can represent an image as a long
vector by uh for example adding all the
rows
but then we would have this huge matrix
that we would need to be able to
transform this vector resulting a lot of
parameters and uh which may make it
difficult
um and the the problem here is that
we're not really using of the spatial
structure of images for example if i
just permuted all the um the elements of
this vector and retrain i would
basically get this i would get their
identical model so it's kind of not
paying attention to which
pixels are close by
to fix this uh problem uh we introduce
convolutional neural networks which is a
refinement of a fully connected network
so here in this example
of a conf net in action
uh so here's a car and you can see that
it goes through a number of layers and
over time it
computes increasingly abstract
representations of the image and at the
end you get a vector representing the
probabilities of the different
object categories
so if you want to play with compnets you
can actually click here for android
carpathi's excellent
demo where you can actually create and
train contents in your browser
so another comment is that confidence
we're going to introduce them for
2d images but they can also
be applied to
texts or sequences which are 1d or
videos which are
so confidence have two basic
building blocks um we're not going to go
through the details um you can take a
cs231 if you want to learn all about
confidence but instead i'm going to
focus on the interface and show how
these things these modules come
so the first is
conf
and so conf takes an image
and the image is going to be represented
as a volume which is a collection of
matrices one for each channel red green
blue
each matrix it has the same
dimensionality as the image
height by
width
and what the confidence is going to do
is it's going to compute another volume
of a slightly different size usually the
height and width of this volume is going
to be equal or
maybe slightly smaller than the input
volume
and uh the number of channels is going
to be somewhat different the way that
coff is going to compute this
volume is via a sequence of filters and
intuitively what it's going to do is try
to detect local patterns with
so here is one filter
and how
it works is i'm going to slap the slide
this filter across the image
and
if i put the filter here i'm going to
kind of align it up with the first
pixels on on the image
um i'm going to compute the dot product
between the eight numbers here and
the
um actually sorry 12 numbers here and
the 12 numbers here i get a single
number which i'm going to write into
this entry i slide the filter over a
little bit i'm going to write into the
second entry and so on
and then for the second filter i'm going
to use to fill up the second output
channel so the number of filters is the
number of output channels
okay so that's all i'm going to say
about conf
the second operation is a max pool which
again takes an input volume and then it
produces a smaller
output volume
it's going to have the same number of
channels and for every slice through the
matrix it's going to
slide
a little
operate max operation over every two by
two or three by three region
so the max over these four numbers is
going to be used for this
number and so on
okay so that's all i'm going to say
about max pool um if you want to drill
into the details you can check out this
demo or you can uh learn more in two
three one
but again i wanna highlight that there's
these two modules one for detecting
patterns and one for aggregating to kind
of reduce the the dimensionality
and with these
uh
two functions along with feed forward
now we can define alexnet which was uh
the seminal
cnn from 2012 that won the image
connection and really transformed my
computer
so how this works is i'm going to start
with my input image
apply a convolutional layer apply max 4
apply another configuration error by max
4 apply three more convolutional layers
by max 4 and then apply three
layers of feet forward
okay so in one line i have um
alexnet
now of course i've underspecified um a
couple of things here
one is um
i haven't specified the parameters those
are to be learned
and each of these functions holds its uh
a private set of parameters that need to
be learned the second thing is i also
haven't specified the hyper parameters
which is the number of channels the
filter sizes and so on which are
actually pretty important for getting a
good performance but i just wanted to
highlight the overarching structure and
the idea that you can compose in a
fairly effortless way
so now let's turn our attention to
natural language processing so here's a
motivating example
suppose we want to build a question
answering system
we have
a paragraph
it's from wikipedia
we have a question
and we want to select the answer from
that passage
from the paragraph so this happens to be
from the squad question answering
benchmark
um so
let's just read this so in meteorology
precipitation is any product of a
condensation of atmospheric water vapor
that falls under gravity
and the question is what causes
precipitation to fall
and the answer is gravity
so to do question answering you have to
do
a fair amount of processing um so you
somehow have to relate to the question
with uh the paragraph but it's not an
exact match some of the words match like
precipitation but some of them are kind
of more subtle like causes is somehow
related to product
and
also the fact that some words are
ambiguous like product can be um
or
multiplication or um output
um so there's a lot of
processing that needs to happen
and it's hard to kind of specify in
advance
so
um
so first things first so words are
discrete objects and neural networks
speak vectors
so whenever you're doing nlp with um
with neural nets you first have to embed
um the words or more generally tokens
so we're going to define an embed token
function that takes
a word or a token x and maps it into a
vector
and all this function is going to do is
it's going to look up vector in a
dictionary
that has a static
set of vectors associated with
particular tokens
so um this is fine and for if you have
a a sequence of words
then you can just embed each word into a
vector to get a sequence of vectors
um there's one
problem which is that the meaning of the
words and tokens depends on context so
this
representation of the sentence is not
going to be a particularly
sophisticated one
so what we're going to do is going to
define
an abstract function
borrowing terminology for programming
abstract function is something that has
an interface but not an implementation
so a sequence model is going to be
something that takes a
sequence of input vectors and produces a
corresponding sequence of output vectors
where each vector in this sequence is
a process with respect to the other
elements so in other words i want to
contextualize these vectors
um
using the sequence models
i'm going to talk about two
implementations of the sequence models
one is recurrent neural networks and one
is transformers
so historically recurrent neural
networks have have been around fog since
the early 90s and uh since
2011 or so became really kind of the
dominant paradigm for doing a deep
learning nlp transformers uh
who came out in 2017 and really has kind
of started
uh i guess transformed the landscape of
deep learning nlp
so on rnn or a recurrent network can be
thought of as reading
you know a sentence left to right that's
a kind of intuitive way to think about
it so
we have um you know a word which gets
mapped into a vector
that produces some hidden state
and then i'm going to read a second
uh
input vector and i'm going to update
this hidden state
with along with this thing that i just
read into a new hidden state
and then i'm going to read another
input vector updated state
and repeating
and and again okay so at the end of the
day
i have the sequence model because that
maps um input sequence into an output
sequence
and
i notice that each vector here now
depends on not just the
us
the input
vector but
um into the left so if you look at h3 h3
depends on x3 x2 and x1
all this computation graph
so the intuition again is reading left
to right updating hidden state as you go
along it's kind of like a memory
um
one thing i haven't specified is what
this function that takes an old hidden
state an input and updates the hidden
state
so i'm going to do that next there's two
types of implementations i'm going to
talk about one is a simple rnn
um so
the contract here is i'm going to have
an old hidden state
an input and we're going to want to
generate a new hidden state of the same
dimensionality
and the way a simple rnn works is it's
uh i take the hidden state multiply by a
matrix
um
take the input
um multiply by matrix
and i add these two and i apply an
activation function
so it's fairly simple and one other way
to think about this is that this is
really the feed forward function applied
to concatenation of h and
x okay so one problem with a simple rnn
is that
it suffers from the vanishing gradient
problem
if you have long sequences then the
gradients start vanishing so lstms or
long
short-term memory were developed to
solve this problem
and the way that this works is uh the
interface is the same
and
the implementation is some
rather involved thing that i'm not going
to explain
but
intuitively you should black boxes and
think about lstms this is just a way to
update the hidden state
given a new input but without forgetting
the past
remember up here for that simple rnn we
can think of it as this feed forward on
x and
h
which are treated kind of equally lsm
lsm's kind of privilege h and make sure
that each doesn't get forgot while going
through this era
okay so
now we have our
sequence model on rnn which
produces a
sequence of vectors which and the number
of vectors depends on how long the input
sequence is
so suppose we want to do classification
we need to somehow collapse that into a
single vector so i'm going to define
this function collapse which takes a
sequence of vectors and returns a single
vector
so you can intuitively think about this
as summarizing the collection of vectors
as one
there's uh three um common things you
can do you can just simply take the
first vector
you can take the last vector or you can
take uh the average of
all the vectors so if you're doing text
classification you probably want to pick
the average to not privilege any
individual word but as we'll see later
if you're trying to do language modeling
you want to take class
so here is an example text
classification model that we can uh
develop
um the score
or let's say binary classification is
going to be equal to
taking the input
sequence of tokens
to embed all the tokens into a sequence
of vectors and now you can apply
a sequence model for example the
sequence rnn
um and you can do this three times that
gives you um depth just like we talked
about for feed with forward networks
and now you can collapse that into a
single vector take the dot product to
get a number out
so this um
these types of
functions that where the input and
output have the same type signature are
really handy because then you can
compose them with each other and get
multiple steps of computation
so
recurrent neural networks are
work generally fairly well but
they suffer from one problem is that
they're fairly
you know local
and um
so
the one problem
that oh so this is a problem that we're
going to try to
address
with transformers
so uh introducing transformers is fairly
involved
so i'm going to step through
introduce a few things before actually
defining it
so the core part of a transformer is
the tension mechanism
and
the intention mechanism
takes in a collection of vectors
of input vectors and a query vector
and then outputs a single vector
and intuitively what the tension is
doing is it's going to process
y by comparing it to each of
these x's
okay
so
mathematically what this is doing is um
you start with the query vector
i'm going to multiply a matrix to reduce
its dimensionality in this case from six
to three
um i'm also going to take um
the x
transpose which is
each row here
is um one of the input vectors x1 x2 x3
x4
i'm going to reduce its dimensionality
to also
three dimensions
and now i can take the dot product
between these x's and y's
so that's going to give me a four
dimensional vector
of of dot products intuitively measuring
this uh
similarity between x and the x's and the
y
so now i can take those scores
and i can uh turn them into
probabilities by taking a softmax so a
softmax
exponentiates the scores and normalizes
that into a probability distribution
so now i have a distribution over the
input vectors x1 x2 x34 it's a four
dimensional vector
i can use that
those probabilities as weights to
when i multiply by x
to take a weighted combination of the
columns of x here
so
for intuition if um one of the
and the inputs has a very high
probability let's say it's a 0 0 1 0
then i'm just going to
pick out the third
input vector so in general this is a
distribution so this is kind of like
softly picking out um which input vector
is similar to y
okay and then finally i'm going to
reduce the dimensionality to some lower
dimensional object
so
similarity is can be a multifaceted
thing so
one thing that the transformer does is
allows us to use multiple attention
heads so i'm going to repeat this
process again
taking the query vector taking the input
vector comparing them getting a
distribution over the input vectors and
using that distribution reweight the
input vector so i'm selecting out softly
in a vector and i multiply it by matrix
to reduce the dimensionality i've done
this twice but in general you can do
this um any
for
16.
so now i concatenate these vectors so i
have a four dimensional vector from this
computation four dimensional vector from
this computation i can concatenate them
into a eight dimensional vector and now
i can reduce the dimensionality back to
the original
dimensionality that of the of the inputs
okay so that was a kind of a very
involved uh you know process but at the
end of the day you can think about this
as taking y comparing it with the x's
and selecting out the one that's
most similar
and
doing some dimensionality reduction in
the process
okay so that's attention um
the transformer uh uses something called
self-attention which means that the
query vector is actually going to be the
import vectors themselves
so if attention self-attention takes a
sequence of
input vectors
and then it's going to output the same
a sequence of output vectors
where the first vector is i'm going to
stick x1
into the query vector for y and compute
the tension
and then x2 and x3 and x4
so each of these vectors is
comparing
a particular input vector with the rest
of imperfectors and doing some
processing
so in other words i've basically
generated a sequence of vectors where
all the objects all
n squared of the objects have allowed uh
i've allowed them to communicate with
each other directly
um so in contrast with rnn
um
we have representations that have to
kind of do proceed step by step and the
number of steps is the length of the
sequence which causes these long chains
which
prevents uh kind of fast propagation
whereas attention um solves uh this
problem
so one kind of slight uh
you know comment is that you know i've
speaking very vaguely and intuitively
about these things um
trying to provide as much intuition as
possible and i it's really you can't
really be more precise because i'm again
not specifying uh the actual computation
i'm only specifying the kind of the
scope of possible computations that
can be done once
the parameters are learned from data
okay so that's the tension
mechanism you can think about this as a
sequence model that just takes uh input
sequence and
contextualizes the
input vectors into output vectors
so there's two other pieces i need to
talk about um to before i can fully
define the transformer layer
normalization and residual connections
so these are really kind of technical
devices to make the final
neural network easier to train
i'm going to package them up into
something called add norm
and it's also a has a type signature of
a sequence model where i have an input
sequence of vectors and i spit out the
corresponding set of contextualized
vectors
and the intuition behind this is i'm
going to apply f to x safely
so let me explain what that means
so add norm of f x is equal to
i'm first going to take x and apply f to
it
okay so
why is that not good enough
well remember that um
in
uh these these functions are under
specified so at the beginning of
training they're basically not doing you
know anything
and so they're basically kind of junk
and if this is junk then anything that i
build on top of it is also going to be
uh pretty junky
so what i want to do is add a residual
connection
so residual connection is a kind of
escape hatch that allows x to be
propagated through a verbatim
so that means if f is jumped at least i
have x
so then i'm going to add a layer norm
function on top of this
so layer normalization
is just a way to
make sure that this vector is not too
big or not too small because big vectors
and small vectors
result in exploding gradients or
vanishing gradients which stalls
training or mixed training
diverge
so specifically what layer norm does on
a single vector is that it treats these
as a set of elements and it subtracts
the mean of those elements and divides
by the standard deviation to kind of
standardize the the magnitude and
of the vectors
okay so
in summary add norm of with a particular
function is just applying f to x uh
safely
okay so now i'm finally ready to define
the the transformer block
and this is again a sequence model that
takes this sequence of input vectors and
spits out a contextualized set of output
vectors
and this is just uh intuitively
processing each x i in context
so there's only one line here we've done
actually a lot of most of the hard work
so the transformer block on a
sequence of vectors is going to be
x and you apply a tension
that allows all the
the vectors to talk to each other
and then you want to normalize to the
end to do this safely
um and finally you apply feed forward to
each individual
resulting vector independently and then
you also want to normalize
and do this safely
so so that's it for
a transformer block
so
now i can
and now we have enough that we can
actually build up to a bird which was
this complicated thing that i mentioned
at the beginning the bird is this large
unsupervised pre-trained model which is
uh came out in
2018 which has really kind of
transformed nlp before there were a lot
of specialized architectures for
different tasks but bird was a single
model architecture that work well across
the many tasks so this is the way um it
works for
you know question answering you take
the
question you concatenate it with the
paragraph
that gives you just a sequence of tokens
and uh what bert does on a sequence of
tokens is it's it's going to embed
the tokens
and then it's just going to
apply the transformer block 24 times
so again the nice thing about having a
transformer block that where the input
and output have the same dimensionality
and type is that you can just kind of
lay it on
and get much deeper
networks
okay so at the end of the day bird gives
you a sequence of vectors which are
highly contextualized and
nuanced and it contains a lot of rich
information about the sentence
um and from there you can either use it
to drive classification
of let's say binary classification
directly by collapsing the vectors into
one vector or you can use it to
select out
an answer to the question
and i'm not going to go into details of
how that works
so so far we've talked about how to
design functions that can process a
sentence a sequence of tokens or vectors
um but we can also uh generate new
sequences
and the basic building block for
generation is i'm going to call it
generate token
and it's um it's you take a vector
x and you generate a token y
and this is going to be this is kind of
the reverse of embed token which takes a
token and gener produces a vector
and the way january token is going to
work is that it's going to actually use
this as a subroutine it's going to look
at all the possible candidate words that
one could generate it's going to embed
those
to and take the dot product of x to get
some sort of similarity between the
vector and a potential candidate
generation
now we have some scores we apply the
soft max to get a distribution
over possible words and then we can
generate from that probability
so
here
building on top of generate token we can
do language modeling where
the input is a sequence of words and the
output is the next word
um so this is actually fairly simple
since we already have all the
essentiality tools so language modeling
of x is you take x
you embed them into tokens the crucial
step is that you stick it through a
sequence model remember a sequence model
um does fancy stuff and it turns this
sequence of um kind of primitive
vectors into contextualized vectors
which are um have contained more
information
and then it collapses them and this time
you you generally want to use the the
last
vector
because that's closest to the word that
you want to generate next
and then that gives you just one vector
and you can use that to generate a token
okay so
finally
we can take language models and we can
build on top of them um
to create what is known as a sequence to
sequence model
so this is perhaps one of my kind of
favorite uh interfaces because it's so
versatile
so the basic idea is that you have an
input which is a sequence
and you are trying to generate another
sequence which is output and sequences
are very
general you can use sequences to encode
basically any sort of discrete
output
and the way we're going to do that is
just using you know a language model
so
um remember a language model takes the
sequence and predicts the next token so
i can take start out with x
and i can use a query the language model
to generate the next token and then i
can feed this token attach this token to
the history query the language model
again to generate the next token and so
on and so forth until i'm i
am done
um so this is by and large how a lot of
the state-of-the-art
methods for for example machine
translation works for generating a
translated sentence given input sentence
or document
summarization or semantic parsing
each of these are sequence can be framed
as sequences sequence tasks
based on
usually these days um
basically bird and transformers
okay so that was a really quick and
high-level world when tour of different
types of differentiable programs from
deep learning so we started with
uh now in in hindsight it seems kind of
very simple feed forward
networks
then we looked at images and looked at
convolutional neural networks which were
built on conflict conf layers and max
pool layers
and also feed forward so the nice thing
about packaging this in the module is
that now this actually is used in
transformers in the different
places as well
for us text and sequences
we first have to embed them into a
sequence of vectors
and then we have kind of two
choices we can either
use
recurrent neural networks
or we can use transformers which are
based on
attention
um we can use sequence models collapse
it into a vector to drive classification
decisions
or we can use them to generate
new sequences as well
so there are many details that are
glossed over in particular
the some of the architectures have been
simplified so i encourage you to consult
the original source if you want the kind
of the actual
um
uh the full gory details another thing i
haven't talked about is learning any of
these models
it's going to be using some variant of
stochastic gradient descent but there's
often various tricks that are needed to
get it to work
but maybe the final thing i'll leave you
with is the idea that
all of these of differential programming
which is that all of these complex
models are built out of modules and even
if you kind of don't understand or i
didn't explain the details i think it's
really important to pay attention to the
kind of type signature of these um
of these functions
as well as with an intuitive idea of
what each of these are doing
okay so that ends this module thanks for
listening